Hi everyone, this is
Dr. Dosha Cummins. I
am a faculty member
on the Arkansas campus
and I will be reviewing
with you today
the pharmacologic
management of GALP.
I want to point out that
my email address is on
this first slide as well
as my work phone number.
Please feel free to
reach out to me if you
have any questions
about this topic. I'm
more than glad to
discuss any questions
you have via Zoom or
email or via phone.
So our objectives
were outlined on
the CPG, so I will
not repeat those.
So let's get started.
Regarding the pharmacologic
management of gout,
we are generally
looking at two broader
categories of management.
One is the acute treatment
of an acute episode or
an acute attack, and
those drug therapies
will target inflammation.
We primarily use non
-steroidals, corticosteroids,
or colchicine. I will
review a few other
agents that I've listed
here under the acute
treatment bullet point.
But again, we primarily use
non-steroid as
corticosteroids or colchicine.
Currently, one is not
preferred over the other. You
will see preferences in
clinical practice and you
may develop your own practice.
But we primarily look
at comorbidities, which a
patient may have as far as
which one of these we choose.
You see I've placed an
asterisk by non-steroidose,
corticosteroids, and
colchicine, and that is
because I wanted to mention
that these agents can
also be used for the acute
management of pseudogoud or
calcium pyroclosate disease.
And really beyond that,
I won't be speaking
a lot about pseudogoud.
We'll primarily be
talking about the
management of goud itself.
So the second big bullet
point is the second
consideration in the
treatment of gallant, and
that is the prophylaxis
of future episodes
and patients in whom we
deem that's necessary.
And we use urate lowering
therapy in those patients.
And you'll see we have,
again, a limited number
of options. We only
have three medications.
Two of those are
xanthine oxidase
inhibitors, and one is
the drug probenicid.
So this second slide repeats
what I just showed you,
except I've added in sort
of an in-between category,
and that is this transition
to urate-lowering therapy.
And what this refers to is
the patients in whom you
think it's appropriate to
start prophylactic therapy
for future episodes of
gout, and they're currently
having an acute gout
episode. There's a transition
process where we start them
on a urate-lowering therapy,
perhaps after we get an
acute episode under control,
and they're actually on
an anti-inflammatory agent
plus a urate-lowering
therapy agent for a period of
time. And I'll reiterate
this point later in this
discussion, but the reason
we keep them on an anti
-inflammatory agent when we
start them on a urate-lowering
therapy is because starting
a patient on a urate-lowering
therapy agent actually
predisposes them to having
another gout flare. And
that's because what we're
doing is we're really shifting
uric acid into the tissues
because of how we're
increasing its elimination.
And it predisposes these
patients to another
flare. So we don't want
to do that when we've just
finished, hopefully,
or started treating an
acute flare. So we have
this need for a transition.
So if you have questions
about that, please
let me know. I'll try
to reword that a little
bit differently a few
slides down the road here.
So, just focusing on
acute treatment. Patient
comes in today, they
have an acute episode.
General principles,
we treat acute
episodes with pharmacotherapy.
From a chronic disease
standpoint or management
standpoint, there
are non-pharmacologic
management considerations,
such as dietary adjustments.
But in acute episode,
we treat with drug
therapy because it's
just extremely painful,
ideally, because we are
managing an inflammatory
process. We try to treat
it within the first 24
hours, which which patients
are going to want to do
that anyway, because,
again, it's very painful.
Once we're beyond
24 hours, those
inflammatory mediators
are well established
and it's a little
harder to manage.
a key point here if you
have a patient with a
history of gout who's had
multiple episodes who is
on ULT and they have a
flare on their prophylactic
ULT therapy go ahead and
continue that treatment
if they're having an
acute episode because if
you stop it they're going
to have to restart it
and they're already having
an acute episode so our
anti-inflammatory agent
of choice We'll manage
the acute episode and
just keep the ULT ongoing.
And that is a patient
counseling point. So that's
something we want to
tell our patients is,
again, if they have an
acute flare and they've
been on this ULT therapy,
go ahead and continue
it and we'll manage the
acute therapy or sorry,
the acute episode on
top of everything else.
so again three categories
of of medications primarily
that are go-to for managing
gout one is non-steroidals
you will learn and have
learned a lot more detail
about non-steroidals
elsewhere in their curriculum
so i will primarily hit
the highlights here they of
course inhibit prostaglandin
synthesis and that is
their primary reason for
utilizing them here is we're
really trying to knock down
inflammatory mediators.
And, of course, we have an
analgesic response as well.
In addition to being used
for acute management of
gout, they are also used
in that transition to ULT
because we want that
background anti-inflammatory
mechanism as we start the
uric acid learning therapy.
The toxicities can be
numerous. I've highlighted
some of the more common
ones, dyspepsia, GL
ulceration, potentially
renal toxicity because
of that prostaglandin
effect, and then bleeding
because of that platelet
inhibitory effect.
There are three non
-steroidals that are actually
FDA approved for managing
gout. However, we can use
any of the non-steroidals
for treating gout. The
trick is that some non
-steroidals need a higher dose
to get that full anti
-inflammatory effect versus the
analgesic dose. And the
example I like to use is
if you're a fan of
ibuprofen, for instance, when
you have a headache and
you take 400 milligrams for
an anti-inflammatory effect,
you generally need more
than that, 600 or 800. So
that's not something you
have to memorize from a
dose standpoint, but I do
want you to be aware of
that concept because it's
important when we're
treating something like gout.
And then lastly, this
is a drug class that in
patients with baseline
renal insufficiency,
they're probably not
the best choice for
managing acute gout because
of that toxicity. And
because of the toxicity
profile in general,
many times elderly
patients cannot tolerate
them because of the
other comorbidities
that they may have,
which cross over
with some of the non
-steroidal toxicities.
So a second class we
can use, again, for the
anti-inflammatory piece
are corticosteroids.
They are primarily used just
for the acute management
of gout. they're not used
for prophylaxis because
they don't impact uric acid
levels and rarely used for
that transition period
because of just the toxicity
profile as you probably are
aware of by now there are
numerous adverse effects
potentially with corticosteroids
it's even short-term
insomnia mood changes
hyperglycemia fluid retention
but in the right patient they
can sometimes be the best
choice for an acute flare.
I've listed a very specific
dosing on here, and I
don't intend for you to
memorize this, but I do want
you to be cognizant of the
fact that when we do use
prednisone for something
like acute gout, we want to
use the correct dose, because
if we underdose it, then
we may not be giving the
patient enough to really
knock down that flare and
provide them enough relief.
So again, you don't have
to memorize the dose, but
just be aware as you
move into taking care of
patients that you want to
use the appropriate dose
so that you treat the acute
episode appropriately.
So we use oral
prednisone a lot as our
corticosteroid of
choice for acute gout.
You may use interarticular
injections of
steroids if you've
got someone who cannot
tolerate the oral
toxicity profile or
the toxicity with oral
prednisone, rather.
And then lastly, you
may have occasions where
IM steroids are what is
chosen for the patient,
but we predominantly use
oral corticosteroids.
And then the last
medication class, which is
really only one medication
within that class
for acute GALD, is the
old drug colchicine.
colchicine has a lot of
mechanisms of action it
ultimately is an anti
-inflammatory which fits with our
theme here also inhibits
microtubular polymerization
and it can be very effective
in the management of
gout it is used outside
of just acute treatment it
can be used again in that
transition over to starting
your acid lowering therapy
it can be used for long
-term prophylaxis, but
that is less and less so
compared to 20 years ago. I
know it's a little confusing
because in this day and
age, when we talk about
prophylaxis of gout, we're
almost always talking about
drugs that actually lower
uric acid and colgicine
doesn't do that. So it's
somewhat of a mixed bag in
that it's used mostly for
anti-inflammatory purposes
in acute gout, but You're
sometimes seeing it used
for prophylaxis when
patients can't tolerate the
true uric acid-lowering
therapies. So a bit confusing,
so if I don't explain that
well by the end of the
lecture, let me know, and
I'll try to clarify more.
But toxicities
really are one of
the things that limit its use.
GI, as you can see,
nausea, vomiting, diarrhea.
We can see neuropathy and
bone marrow suppression,
but that's primarily
if it's used long term,
which, again, is one of
the reasons we don't see it
used for long term
prophylaxis like we once did.
You will still see patients
on it for prophylaxis
after they're started on
it for acute treatment.
However, we really
try to utilize the
true ULT drugs more from
a safety standpoint.
They're just a
little bit cleaner.
A key point here,
colchicine can have a lot
of drug interactions, and
I didn't list them all
out on the slide because
there are too many, but
just please remember that
if you've got patients who
are taking other medications
that inhibit the CYP3A4
system, that you may
have to adjust doses as
far as how much colchicine
you give them for an acute
episode, and then And
also, unfortunately, it
interacts with drugs that
interfere with P-glycoprotein
as well. So a bit of a
complicated drug to use,
but we're using it fairly
short term for the acute
treatment of colchicine.
It's a little simpler
because we don't
have to worry as
much about especially
some of these
chronic toxicities.
So last thought on colchicine.
It works best if you initiate
it within 36 hours of
symptom onset. But patients
will start something or want
something well before 36
hours. So we generally don't
have to worry about that.
But I do want you to know
that from a pharmacologic
standpoint, it just doesn't
work as well after 36 hours.
And again, that's because
that inflammatory process
is very well established.
I do want you to know this
one dose for this one lecture.
And that's because
it's very specific.
The dose for acute treatment
of gout with colchicine
is 1.2 milligrams once.
and then an hour later the
patient takes another tablet.
So they take 2.6 tablets
and then an hour later they
take one and that's it.
That's the entire dosing for
acute gout. And I mentioned
this because at one time
we used a much different
dosing strategy which
frankly made patients really
sick from a GI toxicity
standpoint. So we now have a
very specific dose again
just for the acute treatment.
So for the rare patient
that you see continue on it
for prophylactic therapy,
they are on a really small
once-a-day dose typically.
And you don't have to
necessarily memorize that.
I just want you to know
the concept that when it
rarely is used long-term,
it is a lower dose
than what we see here.
So the last category
for acute treatment is
reserved for those
patients who do not respond
for or to non-steroidals,
corticosteroids, or
colchicine, and that
includes our biologics.
As you know, humans can no
longer make a functional
uricase enzyme. We've got
too many mutations in our
genetics for that, and so
we just can't break down
uric acid, which is why
we're predisposed to having
gout, or many patients are
predisposed to having gout.
So if you look at our
biologists, we have a synthetic
version of uricase, which
is a pretty neat thing
that we can use in patients
who do not respond to our
other therapies when they
have an acute treatment.
We also have an IL-1 inhibitor
specifically
indicated for gout.
And again, this will be
the rare circumstance
when And these other
acute treatment
options have not
benefited the patient.
And then lastly,
again, very rarely,
when all else fails,
we can see ACTH,
our synthetic
version of ACTH use.
Okay, so now we're to the
prophylactic portion of this
to finish up here. So
prophylaxis for GAUD and uric
lowering therapy or ULT
are generally talked about
as one in the same because
we almost always use a
drug that is going to lower
uric acid for prophylaxis.
So I won't be saying
anything more about using
colchicine because that's
really less and less the case.
So does everyone need uric
acid lowering therapy?
No, we've got some
guidance here from the
American Arthritis
Foundation and what their
recommendations are. If
you've got a patient with
more than one TOFI,
if you already can see
radiologically that there's
joint damage due to gout,
or if they have at least
two attacks a year,
those are the patients who
are going to benefit from
lowering uric acid from a
prophylactic standpoint.
So, again, to reiterate my
transition point earlier,
you can start this if a
patient is having an acute
episode this week, for instance,
and you've started your
anti-inflammatory agent
of choice based on their
comorbidities. You can go
ahead and start them on a uric
acid lowering therapy if
they're not already on one.
The trick is make sure you've
started the anti-inflammatory
already. And that's,
again, because ULT, because
you're mobilizing uric acid
into different places where
you can have a gout attack,
we don't want to precipitate
a flare or exacerbate an
episode they're having
now. So we've got this overlap,
this transition period.
so as far as the uric acid
lowering therapy itself
these patients will more than
likely have elevated serum
uric acid levels at baseline
and our goal is to get
them down to a serum uric
acid level less than six
generally speaking so how do
we do this we've got two drug
classes that we do this with
xanthine oxidase inhibitors
is the first class and
just as a reminder we have
hypoxanthine, which is a
breakdown product of purine,
purine catabolism. It is
normally eliminated via
xanthine oxidase in a couple
steps to become uric acid.
So our body normally does this.
Well, one of our xanthine
oxidase inhibitors is
allopurinol. And allopurinol
is a purine itself you
know very similar structure
here so it basically
um competitive competitively
inhibits xanthine
oxidase um so we've got
it's sort of a distractor so
and we've got less uric acid
form because allopurinol
is basically inhibiting
the enzyme that ultimately
is responsible for the
formation of uric acid
so mechanism of action is
summarized here on that
first bullet um so it is
currently our preferred first
line ult for the chronic
management of gout it's been
around for years and years
and years and you will
see it in many of your
patients that you pick up with
the history of gout in
your practice. It also is
indicated for the treatment
of hyperuricemia and cancer
treatment to prevent tumor
lysis syndrome, which is a
different conversation, but
I wanted to include that
because you will see that
in your patients as well.
It itself is metabolized
via xanthine oxidase,
the enzyme it's inhibiting
to a metabolite.
And aloxanthine, by the way, is
the same thing as oxypurinol.
And the metabolite
also inhibits xanthine
oxidase. So very effective drug
therapy, which is why
we use it so much.
So the adverse effects
are generally rare,
or sorry, mild and
reversible. Well, I guess
rare is correct, but
mild and reversible,
dyspepsia, headache, diarrhea.
The big thing to remember
with allopurinol, because
so many people take it, is
that if a rash develops,
if the patient develops a
rash, they should stop this
medication immediately.
And that is because there's
a very specific hypersensitivity
connected to this
allele I've listed on
here that can really be a
serious adverse effect.
These patients can have a
pronounced hypersensitivity
that involves eosinophilia,
leukocytosis, hepatitis, and
even worst case scenario,
renal failure. So we
should tell everyone on
this medication that if a
rash develops, they should
stop it. Now, it's possible
to have a rash that's
not related to this
hypersensitivity, but they need
to come see you to see
if they have these other
things like the eosinophilia,
et cetera, going on.
Certain patients are
predisposed to this over others.
Descendants of certain
Asian populations are more
likely to have this allele
than the general population.
Dosing on this is very
important. And this is
something I do want you to
know because it's important.
We really need to start
patients slowly on this
medication and titrate up
to your clinical endpoint,
which may be looking
at the uric acid level.
We don't want to start
everybody out on too high of a
dose. And that is tied back
to the higher the dose, the
more likely they are to
have the usual side effects.
But the more likely
they are to have this
hypersensitivity if they're
predisposed to it. We don't
check patients with this
allel. It's not recommended
because it's not terribly
common. It doesn't
make sense to test everybody
on allopurinol for it.
But starting at a
lower dose is going
to minimize any
consequences that we
have from an adverse
effect profile.
You can use allopurinol
in patients with chronic
kidney disease, and I mention
that because we do adjust
the dose based on renal
function, and so it's not
a contraindication that
we can't use patients with
kidney disease and
allopurinol, it's just that you
want to make sure you're
using an appropriate dose.
the renal patients or their
very patients who have
hyperuricemia to begin with
a lot of times. And so we
still need to be able to
use this drug. We just don't
want to be too aggressive
with the dosing. Drug
interactions. These are
famous drug interactions with
anything that inhibits xanthine
oxidase will be problematic
with azathioprine and
mercaptopurine. And that
is because they are purine
derivatives, and if you
cannot metabolize them,
then you're going to have
increased adverse effects
from these two chemotherapy
drugs, which are used in
other disease states as well.
Monitoring, please be aware
that with allopurinol,
you do have to monitor
liver function tests, serum
creatinine, and a CBC
or complete blood count.
So our second ULT therapy,
which is also another
xanthine oxidase inhibitor,
is Fuboxastat. It
also inhibits xanthine
oxidase like allopurinol.
However, it does not
have a purine structure,
so it itself is not a
substrate for the enzyme.
It is only indicated for the
chronic management of gout.
It is a medication which
is not really eliminated.
It is hepatically eliminated.
And so it's a little
easier in a sense from a
dosing standpoint when we
look at patients which have
chronic kidney disease.
We've got some similar
toxicities as allopurinol
as far as GI, and we do
have to monitor LFTs.
A thing that stands out
about phoboxostat is for
a number of years now, we
do have a warning about
a potential increased risk
of cardiovascular death
in patients with gout who
already have a history
of vascular disease. So
this is something that's
debated year to year,
whether or not it's really a
connection as far as CV
risk and the drug. However,
it still exists in a black
box warning, and it's
one of the reasons it's
not considered a first
-line agent over allopurinol
for gout prophylaxis.
So not surprisingly,
because it inhibits santhine
oxidase, we've got the
same drug interactions that
we saw before with azathioprine
and mercaptopurine.
Similar monitoring, we
want to monitor liver
enzymes in CBC. You
don't have to memorize it
based on in a two to four
months. I just wanted
to take an opportunity
to point out that with
neurotherapies like this,
sometimes that monitoring
is very specific.
That's something you can
always look up. You don't
have to memorize it.
And again, you don't you
don't see monitoring serum
creatinine because it's
not really eliminated,
which is a distinction
between it and allopyrinol.
And I only included
the dose here to point
out that it's a
pretty standard dose.
As with allopurinol, you
have to titrate the dose.
Okay, so last drug to talk
about here, and this is
the uricosuric class of
the ULTs, or prophylactic
therapies, and we only have
one. There have been several
on the market over the
years, but we only have one
still standing, and that is
probenicid. So as a reminder,
when we look at how the
kidney handles uric acid,
uric acid is secreted,
it's excreted, or it's
filtered rather, it's
secreted, and it's reabsorbed.
Reabsorption is the primary
method of how the kidney
handles uric acid. And
if we look at specific
transporters, there are several,
but the primary transporter
for uric acid in the
proximal tubule is URAP1.
And so if we can inhibit
this, we can have an
effective reduction in the
reabsorption of uric acid.
But the consequence
of that is you then
have a lot of uric
acid in the urine.
So you've got to make
sure in the patients that
you have on probenicid
that you're enhancing this
excretion of uric acid
into the renal system,
into the urine, that they
need to make sure they
drink plenty of fluids
because they're somewhat
predisposed to now having
uric acid stones because
we've pushed all this
uric acid into the space.
Similarly, if you've
got someone that
already has a history
of uric acid kidney
stones or renal stones,
your lithosis, this
is probably not the
best drug for them.
And then lastly, uric
acid overproducers,
probably not the best
medication for them.
And so I want to wrap back
to a point on this slide
that I did not hit earlier.
So when we look at the chronic
management of gout, many
patients are on allopurinol.
But as you know, most
patients who have gout are not
overproducers of uric acid.
They are under excretors
because we no longer have
uricase. But we still use
a medication that inhibits
the formation of uric acid,
even though most people aren't
overproducers, simply
because medications like
allopurinol are so effective.
And relatively easy to use.
So seems paradoxical, but
it's really not. You know,
it's a point I wanted to
make because you may be
thinking, well, why do we
use alipirinol? Most people
are under excretors. It's
like, well, it's because it
still works. It still works
to manage the condition.
And probenicid, even
though it directly works
where we need it to as far
as enhancing excretion,
it's just challenging
clinically to use. As you
might guess, other things
are involved with these
uric acid transporters,
like other medications.
And so we can have quite a
few drug interactions. So
it gets a little complicated.
So to end up here,
again, competitively inhibits
URET1, used for just a
chronic management, no role
in the acute management.
It does have some toxicities,
such as rash occasionally,
and then drug
interactions, other
drugs that require
those transporters
for elimination,
like beta-lactans,
penicillins. You can see
that. And then lastly,
and this might be
one of the biggest
reasons we don't use it,
it's just not effective
in patients who
have compromised renal
function. Estimated
glomerular filtration
rate less than 60,
it can't get to where
it needs to work.
Therefore, it's not effective.
So summarizing things here,
again, back to that transition
period from acute
treatment to prophylactic
treatment, we will have
patients on an anti-inflammatory
plus our ULT for three to
six months. So it's not
necessarily a short period,
and you will evaluate them
clinically to see how they're
doing. And then what you will
do at some point after this
three to six-month transition
is stop that anti
-inflammatory agent that you
started and leave them on the
allopurinol or the phobuxostat,
or rarely the probenicid,
when we rarely use it.
so in summary the management
of acute gout episodes
should be individualized
based on the comorbidities of
the patient if the patient
comes to you with an acute
episode and they're already
on ULT continue the ULT
don't stop it if the patient
is on an anti-inflammatory
agent for an acute
episode and they have not
previously been on a ULT
therapy and they're going to
start it you can go ahead
and start it at that time.
Just make sure you started
an anti-inflammatory agent
first because again the ULT
therapy may worsen the flare
if the anti-inflammatory
is not already on board.
So these are my core
references and so with that
I will conclude this And
if again, if you have
questions, please feel
free to reach out to me.
Thank you.